what's going on guys this is Rob and
this is to let you all know that I've
got merchandise t-shirts and hoodies and
stuff like that you'll find the link
down in the description you guys have
been screaming at me long enough to have
that stuff so if you guys want it click
the link go check it out and yeah on to
the video
okay so we are picking up with cosmic
Ghost Rider part two and yeah dude I
love cosmic ghost riders I don't know
what it is man like Donnie Cates
everything this guy touches turns to
gold it's kind of bonkers close you guys
were unfamiliar with cosmic Ghost Rider
go check out the Thanos solo run it's
insanely amazing it's it's really really
really good but cosmic Ghost Rider is
basically a Frank Castle The Punisher
with the ghost riders powers and like a
cosmic motorcycle you know here's a
question I have for you guys so like if
there was one song
the cosmic ghost rider would listen to
on repeat when he's like riding around
in space or like fighting people what
song would it be like that's my question
for you guys what song would he be
listening to because I feel like it
would be ac/dc hey I feel like I'd be
something from ac/dc shoot to thrill or
something along those lines I think it'd
be I think it'd be kind of amazing
anyway okay so up to this point it was
basically cosmic Ghost Rider went back
in time and his idea was I am going to
grab baby Thanos they wanna grab down as
a baby and I'm gonna raise him to become
like a hero essentially like I'm gonna
try to rehabilitate the kid and what's
the first thing he does in an effort to
rehabilitate Thanos he takes him to a
bar and I don't know why he thought this
was a good idea but it is kind of
Awesome like it is it is kind of cool
because he's like he's talking to baby
Thanos he's like yeah so so like what
you end up doing is you basically end up
growing up and you end up becoming like
a cosmic serial killer then like BB
damage like what's a serial killer he's
like oh well I probably shouldn't teach
you what a serial killer is it's pretty
bad you're like a cosmic mass murderer
it's like from bad to worse it just
keeps things making things worse and
worse and worse and the Fortuner is like
dude man your kid can't drink in here
and it's like what hold on it's
different though like this is cool
something else and I hope you guys
noticed too is that Frank hassel has a
baby leash those you guys who don't know
what that is back in the day when
parents were dumb they had what were
called baby leashes and basically what
you would do is you would have like this
harness that would go around your kids
chest and then like your it would be a
leash that would attach to the parent so
the kids couldn't wander off parents are
treating their kids like pets they were
treating their kids like dogs and it's
like that's kind of crappy to treat your
child like a dog but nonetheless you
know it's it's kind of
because like the whole taught like this
guy's like let me go get my manager you
know kind of like storms off or whatever
but like baby Thanos is like I want to
learn more about murder like I want to
learn more about what it means to kill
people like like yeah teach me more
about that okay this is the cool thing
about this guy the cool thing about this
it's just good old-fashioned fun like
Cosby goes right before the time cosmic
Ghost Rider appeared up until now is
like you can't take his character
seriously you're not supposed to like
basically it's like what if deadpool
became Ghost Rider and then took off
into space there's basically what is
except it's prana sure which I think
makes it better but like when the
manager shows up and starts talking
trash like like literally he goes to
attack cosmic Ghost Rider and like baby
Thanos comes lunging out of nowhere with
a broken beer bottle and I was like oh
my god baby Thanos is a badass but he's
one of the coolest things is one of most
awesome things to see like babies and
I'm just like freaking out and trying to
attack somebody with a broken beer
bottle it's like the most awesome thing
baby fans could do like okay here's the
thing this needs to be like an ongoing
book because what I understand is a
miniseries but this needs to be like an
ongoing book of like baby Thanos like
baby Thanos has been you know I would
read that baby Thanos adventures like I
would read the heck out of that it would
be absolute like it be dude it'd be the
tits
maybe one of the coolest things and then
like like cosmic Ghost Rider spins
around like a guy who draw he draws a
gun in a restaurant like pardon
everybody relax everybody chill but
again like the whole reason he's here
though the series for a second the whole
reason he's here is because he's here to
quote-unquote meet a friend like that's
that's what he's here for is to meet a
friend and initially nobody knows who
this friend is gonna be and then when
things start popping off and everybody
starts panicking we end up finding out
the friend he's meeting is Galactus now
here's the important thing with this
whole scenario of Galactus remember this
takes place in the past but cosmic ghost
riders from the future and so in the
future that cosmic ghost riders from he
becomes a Herald of Galactus and so he
kind of goes back to the past before all
of that happens and like he's here to
meet Galactus so like he jumps onto his
motorcycle reading a leg listen to ac/dc
and like baby Thanos is asking like
what's purple man doing and like like
everybody just like goes like well he's
probably gonna devour this planet like
he'll everybody on it and it's like war
you know baby thing I was like are you
gonna stop him he's like well I mean no
like this is gonna die let they're gonna
they're gonna die with hope I'm like I'm
not gonna stop them and maybe that I was
like this sounds like fun
like ghostwriters doing a terrible job
of rehabilitating baby Thanos but it's
kind of a funny moment because when when
cosmic Ghost Rider gets up on Galactus
like he's just kinda like okay man like
we need to talk about stuff and in like
the lights this whole response is like
dude like I'm in the middle of like I'm
getting ready to eat this planet man
leave me the hell alone
all right look man I know you're gonna
eat this planet but like I need your
help with what's going on right now I'm
trying to become a good guy again I've
made mistakes
you know I've paid my dues time after
time I've done my sentence but committed
no crime and bad mistakes I've made a
few I've had my share of sand kicked in
my face but I've come through why
because we are the champions my friend
I'm sorry I was looking for a reason to
work that in I really was oh god I was
looking for a reason to work that into
the video I've been trying to find a way
to work that song into a video for
awhile and I have been able to find a
way to do it because I love we're the
champions he's like one of the best
songs ever but no like he literally sits
down and he's like look man I'm kind of
in over my head here so like I need you
to help me sort this whole thing out
well in the middle of all this baby's
hand shouts out fishes only to find that
they're like starfish like basically
cosmic space sharks that are flying
around now of course Galactus takes
those out quick fast and in a hurry and
then that's when like it goes into the
whole thing of life because it goes
writer saying hey look man you've got
these crazy powers just scan my mind
Galactus reads the whole mind of cosmic
Ghost Rider and this is when things get
kind of cool here because this is when
Galactus basically realizes that like in
the future there'll be allies now
they're gonna be allies because of like
a mutual enemy I mean they're not really
friends they never really were I mean
that was the whole the whole basis
behind cosmic Ghost Rider in the
beginning was like why he and Galactus
were never really friends like they were
never besties right like they were never
like friend friends you know we're
working together to try to kill thanos
because he's gone crazy and basically
taken over the universe but like aside
from that like that's about it but it's
kind of a kind of a touching moment here
is because you have this you have this
scenario where Galactus looks at what's
going on and says so what you're trying
to do here is you're trying to kill baby
Thanos because like no no no I'm not
trying to kill anything else in the
gotchas like yes but I think you are
give me baby Thanos give me the child
and Galactus will kill him and like baby
Thanos looks up at it like cosmic Ghost
Rider with like the saddest eyes a
little sad adorable eyes and he's just
like please don't let him kill me and
it's like
my god baby Thanos you're so adorable
and so like in this moment that's
listening for the GRANDMONT in this
moment things suddenly shift and the
reason why is because the watcher
appears now those guys who run familiar
who watch you The Watcher has not been
in Marvel Comics for a long time he
hasn't been minimal comic since original
sin and even before Secret Wars and the
reason for that was because The Watcher
was basically killed by Nick Fury right
like The Watcher saw something he wasn't
supposed to see and Nick Fury like
killed him and took his eyes because
that were all the information the
Watchers saw was stored in his eyes or
just kind of weird and it seems to fly
in the face of original sin itself in
the sense that like The Watcher has all
his information catalogued in these
databases and looks at all the different
universes and so on and so forth but
regardless of the scenario The Watcher
hwacha has been killed and in his place
because of killed because he killed a
watching the rest of the watchers
condemned the original Nick Fury the old
white guy Nick Fury condemned him to
stay on the moon to be chained up he can
never leave and he always just he stays
as the unseen but he's basically hidden
away from like all existence he's more
or less forgotten and his he's cursed
with like seeing all things in existence
kind of creating like a new watcher more
or less and so what what always happened
in Marvel Comics you know it kind of
explains little better what always
happened in Marvel Comics was the
arrival of the watcher was relative to
his scenario right like you go and look
at the old like Fantastic Four stories
and the The Watcher would show up like
he showed up in the original Galactus
trilogy which is really where he was
essentially introduced and it's like I'm
the watcher my job is to watch things
and then occasionally intervene and like
he would intervene only if they were
like a time that there was a time of
crisis or something like that over the
years in Marvel that began to transform
into the watcher only makes his presence
known when there's going to be a big
shift in the status quo so during the
events like Civil War 3 like maximum
security
you know operation galactic storm
different things like that when they
were huge shifts in the direction of the
Marvel Universe The Watcher would appear
and The Watcher would would kind of
signal the coming of major change and
that's exactly what cosmic Ghost Rider
picks up on is ok so like things are
going to change and like originally like
like when when cosmic goes try to talk
to is like ok so you're here to see if
like all this crazy things are gonna
happen and like the watch is like no no
no I'm here because you're trying to fix
what can't be fixed
Thanos is a universal constant now a
little bit aside it aside here for a
second that's true Donnie Cates is not
pulling that out of his backside like
that is true Thanos is a universal
constant those are guys who don't know
what that means
a universal constant is a concept in the
universe that doesn't change it never
fluctuates it never it never never never
ever adjusts for example the molecule
man Owen
Riis his origin story across every
universe is the exact same because he
was a product of the beyonders he was
traded by the beyonders so every
molecule man across the multiverse could
be blown up and then destroy the
multiverse
at the same time just to see what would
happen and so as a result he's a
universal constant the cosmic entities
universal constants these are things
worth like their power their role in the
universe is fixed its unchanging and it
will never become anything other than
what it is and that's the point that's
made with Thanos is it Thanos is a
universal constant Thanos in every
universe will always become a bad guy
he'll always become a villain that's why
if you look at every iteration of Thanos
across across like every single
publishing line that Marvel Comics has
in some former fashion he's always a
villain and so that's kind of like where
it where Ghost Rider sort of chimes in
and says hey look but like we can fix
him though like we can make him better
and the Watchers like okay the reason
why I'm here is because I've come to
witness the worst decisions in the
history of thought and the immediate
consequence thereof that's also in that
in that moment cosmic Ghost Rider's like
okay fine whatever didn't you guys just
go shove off if this is how you guys are
gonna be if you guys are gonna be dicks
about this and fine I'll raise a baby on
my own and I'll go do my own thing and
the Watchers like and there it is I love
I love the way Donnie Cates writes these
characters like I love the way he writes
Galactus in The Watcher it's funny to me
it's a great reprieve from like the
ongoing serious nature of Marvel Comics
a lot of the time but nonetheless cosmic
Ghost Rider kind of takes offense to
this for a second and the Watchers like
do you really not know how bad of a
decision this is because let's be honest
guys cosmic Ghost Rider is like the
least equipped to raise a child like
this guy has no business raising a child
you know it's like okay you know The
Watcher is like you've just created a
timeline and this is now this is an
important thing I'll talk about this in
a second we say you just create a
timeline where basically the Punisher
raises Thanos as a child now let me tell
you guys something if ever there were
clickbait idol if ever there were titled
Thank You Donnie Cates
if ever there were clickbait idol that
would be it but no no okay now here's
here's how for those guys who knew
tamama coming if you're familiar with
marvel bear with me for a second this
next little tidbit is really more for
those who are new to Marvel Comics and
Marvel Comics they have something called
branch universe theory the way through
the branch universe theory works where
it kind of happens is imagine you have
like one straight line right like this
big straight line that's the main Marvel
Universe
alright this fixed this this straight
line is fixed in constant it doesn't
change what happens in the future of
that line might change but the line
itself doesn't change and there are an
infinite number of lines like that earth
1610 which is the ultimate universe
earth to 3/8 which is where madam josh
verses from but you have all these
different you know universes that are
out there now what will happen is let's
say from them in the main Marvel
Universe let's say it just happens
normally spider-man becomes spider-man
Captain America becomes Captain America
and Thor becomes Thor and I hope it
comes walking Yatta Yatta Yatta so on
and so forth now let's say this universe
is progressed up to the way it is right
now and then Ghost Rider makes the
decision that he's gonna kidnap baby
Thanos and he's gonna raise him as his
own alright what this does is it
creatures up it creates a branch
universe you have the main Marvel
Universe where this never happened and
now you have a new universe where it did
and what this does is it gives Marvel
riders the ability to do whatever they
want to write anything they want to and
so what what could conceivably happen
here is that from the beginning of the
series to the end that what what ended
up happening is you end up having Donnie
Cates who would tell this story where
cosmic Ghost Rider adopt babies anos
takes them and raises them as his own
and then like anything could happen
right the whole universe could end up
being destroyed and then like at the end
of the miniseries he ends up going back
putting the baby bag and just undoes it
all or just this universe just keeps on
going on this alternate universe just
keeps on going but that's the way
alternate realities work but nonetheless
in response to this the Watchers like
look man like this is not this is not
how things are supposed to be like
you're basically screwing things up and
so he's like so so what and the washers
like watch this and so what is it happy
here's like this massive explosion next
to a cosmic Ghost Rider knock him on his
ass and when he's like who the heck are
you
we're met by the arrival of a future
cable and a future version of the
guardians of the galaxy which looks like
it kind of includes some variation of
Howard the Duck Rocket Raccoon
I think that's Jubilee I don't know if
that's America Chavez or if that's
what's her name because there's a
there's a in Ultron forever there's a
version of Captain America who's a chick
and is actually I want to say that it's
the daughter of of Luke Cage and Jessica
Jones who becomes the new Captain
America but nonetheless you know it
looks cool it looks pretty awesome cable
joining the guardians of the galaxy
looks it looks pretty badass but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment just but actually no that's
juggernaut that is that's how we're the
duck with the juggernauts powers that's
pretty badass alright with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
you